[Music]
hello and welcome to quad riga an
escalating war of words this week as
turkey's leaders attacked their German
counterparts in harsh personal terms the
political theatrics came as the Turkish
president and his Minister for European
affairs accused Germany of racism and
lies that followed president Otto WANZ
attempt to influence the upcoming German
parliamentary elections by calling on
Turks with dual citizenship not to vote
for the party's currently governing
Germany and Turkey prevailed upon Spain
to detain a German Turkish author it
regards as a threat everyone's
provocation who can stop him that's the
question we want to discuss today with
our guests and it is a pleasure to
welcome D like Corbin
she's a columnist for the Turkish
magazine mediate and she's also a
lecturer at the how to school of
governance she says in the absence of
sufficient social legal or political
force at the domestic level only
concerted external pressure in the form
of comprehensive sanctions can
potentially stop everyone and we're very
glad to have Gulen know my with us once
again he was formerly head of the online
service at Turkey's largest newspaper
crew yet he was dismissed under
government pressure emigrated to Germany
and now writes for media including the
front for alga mine at Saito and he says
air doin's a strong elected leader the
only measure to stop him is the ballot
box pressure from outsides not effective
it's too late the reason is the
hypocrisy of the Western world and
finally great to have Alan Posner back
on the show he's a commentator for the
daily newspaper debate he says
turkey remains an essential ally in the
region but it's time to tell the Turks
they can't elect an Islamist bully and
at the same time hope to become members
of the European Union
boo lent Moo my Turkish leaders
comparing their German counterparts to
Nazis accusing them of racism and lies
that's pretty strong stuff what is going
on
well actually of course that started
since one year it's going on and it's
not a new process it's not just against
law statements as you know it started
with arresting the the German
journalists in Turkey like Deniz you gel
and like banning arrogance political
rallies in Germany it's a continuing
process the thing is a Brogan doesn't
want to hear any kind of criticism so
actually that was the reason that he is
cutting the ties from the West and not
to be a member of you and you know
turning his face to the East instead of
West
so being criticized from West makes him
crazy and that's reason any kind of
critics coming from West especially from
Germany that the country which has a
problem recently with Turkey he becomes
much more angry about it and accuses
German with racism being Nazi etc so
desire but as we just heard German
Turkish relations have been
deteriorating deteriorating for a while
is this latest measure nonetheless a
kind of escalation are we reaching some
sort of point of no return
well I think it's going to escalate keep
going to escalate until certainly until
the elections in Germany perhaps beyond
until the 2019 elections in in in Turkey
and it's because it's it benefits are
done and he's going to escalate this as
much as his can as long as he can
because he's you know this is populist
rhetoric he's conveying a certain
message to his constituency in Turkey
that he's a strong leader and that he
doesn't and Turkey doesn't bow to Europe
it's empty of course and it will
continue unless and until Europe and the
German politicians stand up for
themselves so this is a tightrope act
Alan Posner as you said in your opening
statement you said turkey remains an
essential partner for the West but if
you listen to this language it hardly
sounds like the alliance is functional
no it's difficult but look let's put
these
perspective I can remember when mr.
Silvio Berlusconi was Prime Minister of
Italy he bashed Germany because German I
remember in the last the Kaczynski twins
ran ran Poland now it was one of them
they bashed Germany all the time Germany
bashing is great because you know with
our past we we set ourselves up for it
so I think as far as the war of words is
concerned let's step back a big bit and
wait things like imprisonment of 10 as
you tell and by the way hundreds of
other journalists are much more
important but even there though is I'm
talking about a friend of mine and a
colleague there is also a geopolitical
aspect to this we need Turkey who else
do we have in the region and so as you
say it's a tightrope we can't just
pretend it's just us and an Turkey it's
a whole set up there Syria to think
about there's Russia to think about
there's Iran to think about so we need
somehow to restrain add one without
estranging Turkey so how that can be
done is something we want to address
later but let's take a look first at the
levels of these tensions that are not
only verbal as we've just heard there
have also been detentions of a number of
German citizens including the German
journalist Dennis Tito and most recently
a German author of Turkish origin who
was vacationing in Spain the Spanish
police detained him acting on a Turkish
request for extradition that came by way
of the international police agency
Interpol let's take a look I thought I
was safe in European countries the long
arm of air diwan's despotism and
arrogance could not reach that far
Turkey accuses door onaconda among other
things of having taken part in a robbery
years ago a canler was acquitted of the
charges but the Turkish judiciary has
since
that acquittal the writer believes this
is an attempt to silence him in his
books he writes about turkeys mass
killings of Armenians as genocide a
taboo in Anchorage view a Karla has
lived in Germany for 26 years and has
German citizenship until a decision is
reached on Turkey's request for his
extradition he has to remain in Spain
our critics of heroines such as a Conley
no longer safe in Europe the charges
against our kindly look trumped up a
court has found that in fact they don't
stand so turkeys request looks pretty
thin indeed what's the aim is turkey
really targeting him or are they
targeting Germany well I think it's a
little bit an overrated issue anacondas
issue there are a lot of people who has
whose cases are still open in Turkey and
living in Germany having different
seasoned ships so I think I don't think
that they aimed to arrest anaconda he
had a case in Turkey we knew that and
still continuing and you know when
you're not in the country and when you
you don't go to the to the justice they
sometimes search for you by by using
Interpol and I think that was a
coincidence I don't think that they aim
it because he wasn't a popular and the
politic figure in Turkey recently so I
don't think that it's a critic issue so
did a Corbin that would sound like it's
almost a bureaucratic mistake do you see
it that way I would doubt it I mean of
course we don't know what's going on
behind the scenes but I don't think this
is accidental because this you know the
Turkish government is resorting to a
strategy they have not done before right
going through Interpol and you know the
fact that he is a German citizen of
Turkish origin who has written about the
Armenian Genocide and the Kurdish
question quite critically is important
this is coming again before the
elections in Germany I think the regime
in Turkey is sending a message to both
Turkey and to Germany and the Turks here
and they're going to you know they're
going to keep pushing this but it is of
course outrageous and the fact that he
was even taken into custody
in Spain I find I mean maybe you know
they felt okay we have to do this
because there's an arrest warrant but I
find that I find that actually arthritis
but the thing is his accusations for
Turkey critics about Turkey are not new
like he didn't like anything new about
Turkey so I don't think that that's a
new issue about Turkish and German
relationship
well yes but why do they now being it up
he was acquitted right as the Spanish
police told that he was excellent you
know he was just the question does they
check this idea I mean it was it doesn't
look like a critical issue I think so
regardless obviously there's room for
several points of view on this but
regardless of that the case is a weak
one
Alan Posner shouldn't Interpol perhaps
have acted differently in this case and
how can we prevent abuse of
international institutions like Interpol
by despotic leaders like other one yeah
well I presume that Interpol is gonna be
looking very carefully at the way red
flags go up and people have just taken
off the street from the hotel room the
way mr. canler was and and that's gonna
have to change at the same time there is
a case for cooperating with Turkey and
Interpol in the fight against terror in
the fight against drugs in all sorts of
fights where we really need the
cooperation of the Turkish police who
aren't entirely in the business of
suppressing their own people they're
also in the business actually of
fighting crime we have to it's like you
know in all these cases you have to
differentiate I'm more worried actually
less than that you know you might be
taken off the street when you're in in
in in in Spain or wherever I'm more
worried about the agents of mister add
one here in Germany for instance who you
know if someone is visiting a school
which is run by the Gulen organization
who go to these people an organization
which president heroin sees as a rival
and as behind last year's put attempt
right just for clarification exactly if
you know and they run schools in Germany
by the way very good schools though
there are a rather shady organization
these people are being intimidated
you know members of the girliest
organization which is a legal
organization in Germany but is forbidden
of course in Turkey and used to be
allies of mr. Edwin are they fallen out
are being threatened with their lives
you know I'm that's what you really need
to be worried about the other one has
thousands of people working for him
here in here in Germany actively
intimidating people and of course the
case of the author mr. Arcon Lee is only
one case of a detention of a German
citizens we've mentioned several times a
German journalist has been in jail for
over six months
Dennis Lucho a German translator and a
German human rights worker are all now
sitting in Turkish prisons about a month
ago Germany responded by altering what
had been a fairly moderate approach
toward Turkey heretofore the German
foreign minister who is now the target
of much of the harsh rhetoric we're
hearing out of Ankara approved the
issuance of travel warnings for German
tourists and also told German companies
that investment in Turkey could prove
risky let's see what followed that I
call on all my countrymen in Germany not
to support these parties the Christian
Democrats the Social Democrats and the
Greens are enemies of Turkey that's I
don't want people here to be incited
against each other from outside we're a
democratic country and we refuse to
tolerate any outside interference in our
democracy apart from that I love Turkey
and the Turks and mr. air Dhawan can
change nothing about that who are you to
talk to the president of Turkey talk to
Turkey's foreign minister I didn't know
your limits
and he is trying to teach us a lesson
how long have you been in politics how
old are you
how old are you d like Corbin a pretty
unusual move a head of state telling
citizens of another country how to vote
is this provocation largely symbolic or
could it have a real impact on the
German election there are after all a
large number of German Turkish voters in
this country how are they reacting to
all of this well that's why I think
that's something that remains to be seen
right because this whole dynamic is new
the Turkish citizens living abroad have
been granted the right to vote in
general and parliamentary elections and
referendum only in recent years so this
is something that the Turkish citizens
here I mean this kind of choice they
were not they never had to make this
choice until the recent years we will
have to see how this reacts but I think
maybe just put in five May in historical
context this kind of rhetoric coming
from the Turkish government is actually
also not new you know it just reminds me
for example in the 1990s when a state
minister in Turkey for example accused
three female members of the European
Parliament who were in Turkey for a
fact-finding mission human rights of
being and this I'm using now a softer
language of the you know what he use of
prostitutes from from Europe he said
that and then in the next government he
was given another position again we're
talking about human rights activists
Germany who rights activists in the
1990s Albert II cannot predict a very
renowned human rights activist from
Germany was very active in Turkey and
who was working on tort documentation of
torture he was declared persona non
grata and deported from Turkey so it's
not just aired on regime the Turkish
government the Turkish regime is
authoritarian has always been and
there's a historical precedent for that
and you can also look at historically
how Europe has reacted you know what you
said earlier which I do not share but
this is this this view is very very
prevalent you know this whole idea of oh
we do we need Turkey realpolitik turkey
needs Europe and Germany more than
Germany and Turkey Germany and Europe
need Turkey but given that Berlin oh my
how can turkey afford to alienate
Germany to this degree this direct
election recommendation that was issued
by President Erdogan is being taken
pretty seriously by the German
government I think you
shouldn't be the reason is you know
there are more than like like 4 million
people living here from Turkey half of
them let's say most of them are not
interested they don't have general
passports and just 1 million people have
German passports which has a right to
vote the thing is the people who has
German passports are much more well
integrated to German community so the
people who has the right to vote here in
Germany who has Turkish origins I don't
think they will be so much influenced by
mr. Erdogan the second issue is the
Turkish voters they used to 64 percent
of them were voting for SPD and mr.
Arcon told them not to vote for them but
let's the less thing if they don't vote
for SPD
who will gain from that forever cap so
that will never never worked so it's a
pity and the third thing is let's not
vote for these three parties for whom
they can vote let's talk about three
other parties one party the Lincoln
calls at Logan as terrorists several
times leftist party leftist party the
Liberals fjp the leader of if they pick
called a glue gun let's not say called
compared Aragon with Hitler and compared
to the coup attempt with the ragtag fire
so the the third choice is the racist
the aft alternative for Deutschland so
they actually they don't want the truth
from you so what can the Turkish people
can vote for here so it's it's it's a
silly offer and it won't work I can't
understand why the German community is
being crazy but it won't work here so
then let me ask you this I want
personally given all of that it sounds
like the consequences of this for the
German election actually wouldn't be
that strong is the rhetoric that we're
hearing here in Berlin perhaps also it
partly or largely intended for domestic
political consumption we do have an
election coming up in this car
definitely I mean I think that for mr.
Schwartz Francis the leader of these
Social Democrats it's great to be
attacked by mr. arrow on the last time
he was attacked by mr. Berlusconi who
compared him to a capo in a
concentration camp
right the leader of Italy at the time in
so shorts loves being attacked by
foreign leaders it you know I mean he's
fighting a losing battle against this
macro it's fine if he gets attacked and
mr. Goyal from the same
to go for a minister if he can at the
same time declare I love Turkey but I'm
being attacked by mr. I don't know
nowhere we can address ourselves be
influenced by this that's great
so I think yes it's a lot of it's it's
it's more words than than deeds thank
goodness okay then let's say there's
general consensus here amongst the three
of you that at least the rhetorical the
war of words is perhaps not to be taken
all that seriously nonetheless you've
also all three made clear you do see
Turkey sliding toward increasing
despotism and you do think something
needs to be done about that but I have
two of you saying in your opening
statements there are measures that can
be taken from outside and you opened my
eyes saying it's too late for external
pressure
so let's come now to our title question
which is who can stop heroines
provocations and let me ask you this
we've seen this heating up of the
rhetoric and perhaps also of the actions
partly since the German Chancellor
herself decided to take a stronger stand
about a month ago as I say she left the
course of moderation she said she thinks
there shouldn't be a deepening of
customs union with Turkey does the fact
that Turkey reacted pretty strongly
indicate that maybe outside pressure
from Germany can make a difference well
it's not the the pressure from outside
it's the it's about finance it's about
economy Turkish economy is unfortunately
a weak economy recently since 2011 I
mean it's like when our democracy is
going down our our financial system is
going down too I mean the the the
financial sanctions the economic
sanctions from Europe of course can harm
Turkish economy and can harm our Turkish
government the problem is it's too late
for that since I became in power miss
Marcal came to Germany came to Turkey
for 15 times and recently in one and a
half years she wizard it Ankara and
Istanbul for six times and I'm sure she
didn't visit her hometown six times in
last one and a half year the problem is
today they can decide to put pressure on
an Turkey but it unfortunately it's too
late
it was Turkish democracy better one and
a half year ago it was not of course the
who made things worse in the country and
now they chose to use the economic
measures against Turkey that can harm
Turkey and I'm sure that they're ever in
Turkey the government is afraid of that
as you know they gave a list to Interpol
accidentally with one month ago and
Turkish Turkish government accused let's
say Mercedes and BASF as helping Turks
organizations companies from Germany and
they complained about them to Interpol
and then they said all that accident
they happened so of course they are
afraid of what's going on in the country
and if the investment come or not I just
want to tell you just two small examples
let's say Germany is putting economic
sanctions Turkey the thing is Aragon has
two very big powerful media
organizations in Turkey and one of their
owners called attempts Antioch and at
home son Jack is probably will produce
tanks with a German partner who is it
Ryan Mehta the second thing the Turk is
biggest state contract was given for
wind wind power wind power Mills last
month it had given who gave it the
energy minister who is the Energy
Minister son-in-law of our dog on which
company won that contract his brother
the son in lost brother won it and who
is the partner who is a German partner
Zeman's so if they will put if that
would need to be sincere so given the
fact that both sides need each other
what kind of economic pressure could
work here and from whom and do you see
the political will to exact to that kind
of pressure
Allen no and I don't think it would be a
good idea that the point is we have to
really look back here and look at where
we are the point is that the West is
really under attack from mr. Putin from
China from Islamist terror and in this
big scheme of things Turkey is by no
means clearly on the other side it's on
still more or less on our side we have
to be careful not to alienate and push
them into the camp of our enemies this
is
why we're you know we're between a rock
and a hard place here and so this is why
I think that it's the economic ties to
Turkey Oh excellent very good but in
your opening statement you said somebody
needs to tell Turkey that they can't be
in this yeah well I'm not Aeneas Lee
look for customs union for example I
didn't say custom I'm I'm in favor of
customs union I'm just against them
being member of the European Union
because they don't accept as long as mr.
adorn is in power and it was the case of
course before that they'd simply don't
they don't have the same values the
government doesn't have the same values
as European Union as out of our own
self-respect we should say enough is
enough mrs. Merkel was right privileged
partnership partnership is fine but
that's it it's a question of
self-respect it's a question of are we
are we going cap in hand saying will you
please be members or are we saying look
we're a club we have certain standards
Germany gets some economic support from
the EU in preparation before sorry
turkey for possible membership in the EU
should that be capped yes or no how much
is it four billion or something it's not
much it doesn't matter it goes to the
NGOs not to the government actually so
okay where do you stand
good effect what kind of pressure let's
start with the EU and the whole question
of self-respect and our values accession
status also means something right not
everyone is given an accession status
only those who fulfill the Copenhagen
criteria which includes the rule of law
minority protection etc does turkey
deserve to be an exceptions that still
right so one thing to do it to be done
and this I've said earlier also remove
the accession status cancel accession
status make turkey again a candidate you
know lower its status to candidacy that
will have immediately percussions for
foreign direct investment in Turkey
because accession status has a value if
we're talking about EU being sincere and
you know standing up for its values dare
you start first of all a great second
and you know it's not a first of all
it's a matter of principle even if it's
four billion some of which of course
goes to the Turkish government to the
Ministry of Justice for what rule of law
reform there's no rule of law in Turkey
there's no democracy in Turkey the whole
discussion I think you know we cannot
discuss this based on the assumption
that we have a police who's fighting
against crime so this is rule of law and
if you know government that we need to
cooperate with this
is an authoritarian regime which only
understands a certain language that has
to be used and and actions so what I
would say to dramatic you know
concretely in addition cancel Oldham all
the funds that go from EU for rule of
law human rights reform cancel Turkey's
accession status and economic sanctions
history is full of countries where
economic sanctions has worked it works
because as you also said turkeys reliant
Turkey is not Russia it doesn't have
natural resources
it is so reliant on Europe and we will
see how then and it's a NATO ally also
it will work I believe in that we my
Alan Posner implied that if Europe and
or Germany were to push too hard they
might push Germany right over to the
other side in for example the struggle
against terrorism in terms of also
attempting to keep migrant flows in
check is that a real risk should Europe
be more cautious given the fact that
Europe does need Turkey absolutely like
a huge one took is being criticized more
of course not just the government the
public to there they feel themselves bad
that they're not they're becoming less
fan of Europe and west of course that
that's a huge risk that should be done
very carefully that's why all steps
should be sincere thank you very much to
all of you for being with us today and
thanks to all of you for joining us see
you soon
[Music]